I know it is good when I have nothing
else I can take away from it if I change
it it makes it worse it doesn't matter
what you do if you're like I'm a video
editor if I said okay if I gave you
another hour what would you do to this
short clip well I'd probably do this if
I give you another hour what would you
do to the short clip well I would
probably do this this and this I'm like
go do that and they do that they come
back they're like now what I'm like if I
give you a week what would you do for
the short clip they're like well
I'd probably restructure the whole thing
into just a way cleaner narrative
altogether when it comes to like making
something excellent It's that packaging
and reworking and rework just like
beating the dve it takes what it takes